no man can fully grasp how far and how
fast we have come there is no strife no
prejudice no national conflict in outer
space as yet its hazards a hostile to us
all it's gone West deserves the best of
all mankind and its opportunity for
peaceful cooperation they never come
again
the missions primary goal has been
acheived looking at a large single cell
biological I'd hate to jump the gun but
I think it's time looking at the final
over this one beautiful
we set sail
we ask God blessing
the most hazardous and dangerous and
greatest adventure on which man has ever
embarked this nation will continue to be
a pioneer in the new frontier Space
Station to control visual confirmation
of master of a pilgrim I see it it's
gonna heat you no it's not yes Edie's
come here c'mere c'mere c'mere c'mere
c'mere tell the committee they simple
safe and salt each passing year has seen
our estimate of the probability of life
in space increase more and more
scientists feel that contact is no
longer something beyond our dreams but
is a natural event in the history of
mankind that will perhaps occur within
the lifetime of many of us
there have been Rovers on Mars for 20
years I wonder what this one's found the
sample is a large single-cell
unmistakeably biological the first
incontrovertible proof of life beyond
Earth you're finally a daddy it's gonna
be a big custody battle over this one
that's beautiful
the manner of which we first meet life
beyond Earth may determine the character
of all our subsequent relations let us
never forget the fatal impact we've had
upon innumerable peoples on this earth
people who trusted us befriended us and
who we destroyed by our thoughtlessness
the life we know
the specialist location is unknown we
don't know what it is
this etiquettes back to us we'll risk
all human life we're out of order you
don't know what it can do the life we
know the life we know
perhaps that is where we ought to begin
with ourselves
you